a agulha se fosse Alberto João Alberto a
vendo aqui de uso de voz tá até quando
você vocal comemos gatinho é direto da
choque seram não vai fazer
colocando com neuromuscular junto aí ó
tão esperado escolarizar e a tua
resposta muscular cada um tem a sua acho
que você começa a sentir alguma coisa
agora vai fazer para me dizer com J e
o
esporte
[Música]
e depois para sair você sai por aqui que
tem um segurança ele vai dar certo vocês
vão dobrar à direita você nosso
problemas que ela já foi embora tá bom
não é
[Música]
E aí
Oi
sumiu do show como é que tá ó ó
moído moído Valeu rapaziada Até amanhã
amanhã tem mais
[Música]
o Bluetooth da caixa de som
[Aplausos]
a liberdade
desapertar coisa é
e
eu estou bebendo mas eu
abrir o
vacilo eu vou acabar dessa dessa aí no
hotel
É isso aí galera nós estamos no terceiro
de dúvida vamos nessa vamos lá
o que é que você tá comendo aí é bonitão
Gerald Gerald engraçado ela atendimento
no Jardim II
o moderno meu gatinho o amor bem meu
aqui é meus amigos e o dia hoje começou
no fumo não temos energia direito né só
tá tem que tá ligado porque tá tipo meio
fase que eu falei para minha cara minha
fase aqui um monte de gente entender o
que é melhor fazer porque tem são três
fazer neste né aí só tá fazendo numa
fase de energia vai para cada fase que
tem que ir não sei como ela sabe disso
mas eu sei que cada fase é uma fase né E
aí a vida é isso não é só faz
a gente vai aí no apartamento meu ali
é um pouquinho mais para baixo aqui do
Eusébio e lá deve ter energia e internet
tem que beber nessa lá dormindo
como era seu
Bom dia
eu não sei se aqui naquela época tinha
só que o povo parece que não dava não
agora cadeia que eu não tenho banco mano
não é isso aí não rico amém beijo
eu sou rico mais sai aqui tem ele é eu
porque ela vocês um carro que eu comprei
quando eu assim que eu comecei a ganhar
dinheiro eu era doido para o carro e aí
eu já tive muito muito carro lá cheguei
entendo que oito cada uma vez né nem
Beleza ainda
[Música]
tirei minha música a música que entrou
com quem gostaria da máscara meu pai viu
os cama Turbo
ixe Maria levaram foi tudo viu
o banco Rocheda quem tá morando aqui
agora O Spider né ele paga quero estilo
ar condicionado e tal vou mandar
reformar ele sabe explosão cobra um
lavagem simples em cima ele tá só o
bagaço as rodas
pressão acho é massa era parece não ao
comer fumei foi fumo e aí o que é que
tem aqui mano
carai Oxe coberto para quando a gente
vai na vai para lá no Rio e
E então todos vocês aqui eu vou procurar
um por um viu viu rolandinho
Gabi e Valentina Gabi
o
Gabriel tá todo da minha lista Mateus
Maiara e maraisa
clubinho
passa o tempo que eu sofri um acidente
esse dele aqui para mim consegui fazer o
negócio do rádio aí fazer não consigo
mas se não ele certinho aí é tipo não
quer dar certo daí lá é
E aí
eu
vou fazer estendidas
ali tem uma piscina do tamanho da casa
do [ __ ]
e é isso acaba nunca essa praia
aqui é uma reserva então sempre vai
ficar esse Verde aqui direto aí também
já tô correndo de botar Eita mamãe
minha vida oi tudo bem mamãe
depois de ver ó
E aí
e
chegando está chegando se a gente
cachorrinho Ai que delícia agora tu
barbado né É agora eu tô tipo pagamento
irreconhecível né
não parei vai ser certinho o
o
[Música]
meu Deus está gostoso que legal
apartamentinho
quartinhos é
Que dizes trumento meu as coisas de
tocar de jogar tênis no jogo tênis mais
sei lá
que que era aí Aqui tem um monte de
Campo que geralmente hoje essa
apartamento para trazer meus amigos sei
lá quando tem show alguma coisa assim
então papo cama e todo lugar ele
decorado em nada do jeito que eu adquiri
eu fiquei que uma sacadinha que dá para
aquela outra ali é uma redinha
ou como vocês podem ver meu irmão não tá
bem
lindo não é a mesma para todos
[Aplausos]
E aí eu quero engraçado
e é isso
e
[Música]
[Aplausos]
não esquece de que o diabo Ele tá em
gostei que a gente está cumprindo o que
prometeu tá saindo só de madrugada Tá
mas é para você mesmo é para você de
madrugada que tá aí sem fazer nada que
tá poxa tem nada para ninguém jogando
Minecraft ninguém comendo iogurte um
negócio para eu ficar assistindo e vem
com terceiro dia do venda seu terceiro
dia é
E aí Miguel vem aí Mingau já pensar na
mingau é isso não dá nada outra coisa eu
tô falando com ninguém não
E aí
Eu quero foto
também da piscina
apaixona pela aquela agora não quero
ficar mais do que escutar ouça
[Música]
a
gente faz sexo mais campeonat9 vende as
obras de Goya não é só
se eu mandar ela se eu correr ela. A
a
ingênua que tô mexendo na câmera mas tô
só distraindo vocês para lavar obra dá
uma olhada de rotina né vistoria que é
muito boa você tá sempre olhando
sinalizando para o dinheiro chegar a
olhar para o seu negócio desse Eita
nudes cada qual tem que cuidar dos seus
ovos falar em órgãos e já tiraram o tipo
de leitor de vocês você tem mais de 16
anos tira de diretor para poder voltar
para o Brasil mudar também só se quiser
também Se vocês quiser ver a gasolina r$
15 por favor vou lavar o cabelo Entendeu
meu cabelo e o perguntas eu sinto
saudade do meu cabelo grande porque eu
tive cabelo grande durante muito tempo
eu falo que eu nem lembro eu tive cabelo
grande eu juro por Deus que eu vou nem
passar a mão achando que tem um cabelo
procurando um cabelo que eu não tenho
isso não acontece comigo a única coisa
que eu sinto falta é de ter o cabelo
para quando eu errado do shampoo Eudes
condicionador eu poder botar porque
quando eu vou botar o shampoo o
condicionador é o momento Ah tá eu não
tenho mais aquele tanto de cabelo e aí
você tem que fazer uma margem que é uma
coisa praticamente impossível que é
Sugar tá entendendo mas é isso não é
feio para voltar é igual tentar botar o
esperma betada rola de novo voltar para
o homem não tem como não há caminho de
volta a gente Obrigado realmente é
utilizado todo o condicionador
movimentos no rumo do cabelo o meu quero
que fique até que fique mais e
massageando aqui onde já tá começando o
problema do homem né a calvície isso me
assusta que eu tinha cabelo até aqui tá
entendendo eu tinha cabelo muito que tá
se acabando de eu gosto de cabelo grande
eu queria ter sempre mas cabelo aqui já
tá se acabando todinha se acabando e
ficando aquele foi à frente o cabelo
cacheado atrás bonito eu for lá na
frente para ele não eu vou cortar e vou
começar do zero vou cuidar eu vou tratar
da raiz queria tanto meu cabelo grande
mas assim sabe legal eu Tiraria 2 cm de
rola bater muito cabelo poder é um
besteira vôlei para produzir mas ele já
tá mais grandinho eu já tô começando a
fazer tipo Penteado entendeu Tipo do
pertinho do Ximbinha tem que ter só a
igreja amanhã eu sou baterista da igreja
tá vendo a minha mãe pediu não tenho
saudade de ter cabelo grande ou
perguntando se Demorou tempo as velhas
perguntando se a promessa
saudade é
[Música]
e
Eu
coladinho pode ficar cheio marca jovens
falando vem me molhar acho acho ar
gostoso outro é bom é malhar eu
eu pedi para que vocês comentar seus
vídeos anteriores do vidro Ai que legal
tá fazendo o quê que vocês gostaram de
ver no vídeo que vocês queriam ver vocês
gostaram muito de ver a produção de ver
as pessoas que trabalham bem 24 horas
por dia e a gente tá indo para outra
casa que essa casa aqui é Fala pessoal
mesmo minha só que a produção fica em
outro lugar e eu resolvi junto com a
produção para outra casa alugada assim e
aí lá eu vou deixar vocês ficar mais um
pouquinho com o pessoal dá para você
entender como é que eu trabalho deles
assim a gente curiosidade né cara também
está tentando entender que você esqueceu
gosta quê que vocês acham engraçado tudo
que gostei já já vou show de novo não
vou ficar mostrando todo dia e não puxou
gente todo dia eu tô indo para o show
então fico imaginando que vocês assistir
que mais tarde eu tenho um Show a
assistir você Nossa já tá escurecendo E
ainda tá aí nem vai tomar banho até o
show entendeu então hoje não vou mostrar
o jogo encerrar o vídeo por aqui mas
amanhã no mesmo horário vai ficar pelas
madrugadas mesmo cara Espera aí pelas
madrugadas você que era o Corujão você
quer do Jô Soares você quer vive três
gente assistir junto com Sérgio Bros ele
tá assistindo esse horário clique em
Gostei quero que você comente aqui
embaixo o que que você achou
interessante nesse vídeo aqui foi bacana
aquela hora que você mostrou tal coisa
aí porque eu tô só tentando tirar as
medidas aqui para poder fazer mais aí
para você tá bom Vou ficar aqui aqui em
gostei aí esse é o vídeo três então tem
o dois e um logicamente por isso que
esse é o 3 se não tenho dois primeiro
esse automaticamente ver o primeiro que
assim para teu quarto Eu Preciso desses
como terceiro né enfim vamos ver se ele
tem esse espinho até o sétimo daqui a um